you really want to do this tv bomber
i'm coming for you in december twice man
these enemy outfits are very demeaning
[Music]
hey dear cowboy word on the street here
there's number one seed out there for
the picking you told me you'd forget to
pass i'd explain myself but this shows
like cooper one big rush
i haven't had the number one seed since
the year i got drafted i was picked
before you oh everyone was picked before
me i'll show off
where's my cool falling song
i feel like i'm in the crosshairs of the
woke anime mob don't tell me the
playoffs already started you should keep
your distance
i thought you didn't believe it distance
no come on where the bounty hunt
thank you little boy yo he's actually a
bad adult man it's ours fram quick micah
could become a real member of the cowboy
oh that's right i odell beckham forced
my way to the number one seed come to
copenhagen just wait till my dad vlogs
about you
damn your beauty loves the onesie next
bounty the turkey leg i'm eating this
regular season award we're on it
just wait till 2017
[Music]
okay i'm out and they won a super bowl
but imagine next year when they do have
me
my decision making is sound this will
not happen again all right fine i'll go
to the colts